if you ask me which president has most
weaponized their attorney general i
immediately think of donald trump and
william barr william barr has been a
hatchet man for donald trump interfering
in the mueller investigation
putting out that insane propaganda
letter pretending as though the mueller
report was going to completely exonerate
donald trump despite specifically saying
that it can't do that
william barr has been a uh player
uh with respect to the protests that
we've been seeing and
seeing and the use of force against
protesters and william barr yesterday
was interviewed by cnn's wolf blitzer
and it is a veritable house of horrors
this is one of the sickest interviews
i've seen
and what's sick about it is that william
barr
sometimes there are propaganda
mouthpieces
who know that they need to sort of put a
nice coat of paint on their propaganda
right they need to dress it up they need
to make it sparkle
william barr is not even pretending to
care
about the brazen and disgusting nature
of how he is just going to get behind
any crazy notion donald trump brings up
about protesters
or about vote by mail or whatever else
so let's get right into it you've got to
see this this is unbelievable
barr was asked by wolf blitzer
uh what trump has let me let me back up
i'm getting ah i'm shot out of a cannon
i'm getting ahead of myself
donald trump has talked about the
problem with mail in ballots is
a foreign country could print off
millions of them and submit them
and um there's of course no evidence of
that
so wolf blitzer rightly asks william
barr
what evidence do you have that said
that's something foreign countries could
do
and william barr simply says logic the
answer is logic and wolf blitzer is
visibly taken aback by how stupid this
argument is
and basically as i've said repeatedly
i'm basing that on logic
pardon logic
but have you seen any evidence that a
foreign country is trying to interfere
no i'm saying people are concerned about
foreign influence and if we use a ballot
system
with the system that some you know that
states are just now and trying to adopt
it does leave open the possibility of
counterfeiting
counterfeiting ballots either by someone
here or so you think a foreign country
could do that i think anyone could do it
have you seen any evidence that they're
trying to do that no but most things can
be counterfeited that's why we go to the
trouble of
you know counter of making our money the
way we make it now
you know should we have minnesota print
up our money
on on you know regular parchment paper
so this yeah this is this is the same
thing
mark meadows said to jake tapper trump's
current chief of staff
he said i haven't seen evidence that
it's not
going on which is of course one of these
completely indefeasible arguments that
it doesn't really fall under actual
argumentation
because it's completely indefeasible
it's mumbo jumbo
nonsense to be perfectly frank now then
wolf blitzer asks this this i haven't
seen a wolf blitzer of you for a long
time but he did a good job of of really
getting down to the heart of the matter
on a lot of these issues wolf blitzer
asks
of the three countries china russia and
iran which are kind of the three that
are thrown around as
having an interest in meddling in the
election not necessarily
in you know in favor of the same person
but
the evidence that china and iran are
interfering is of course
far less uh prevalent than that of
russia
and maybe you're not going to be
surprised at which one
william barr selects here russia china
and iran
are seeking to interfere in the u.s
presidential election for various
reasons but mostly they want to sow
dissent in our country
exacerbate racial tensions etc like that
of those three countries that the
intelligence community has pointed to
russia china and iran which is the most
assertive the most aggressive in this
area
i believe it's china which one china
china more than russia right now yes why
do you say that because i've seen the
intelligence that's what i've concluded
what are they trying to do i'm not going
to discuss that to this but they're
trying to
help who who i'm not going to get into
that
more aggressive than russia yes because
the
u.s intelligence community trying to
influence the united states yes
yeah super convincing right i mean
there this is a real opportunity to talk
more generally about interference
and meddling and they could actually
have had a conversation about listen
there's a long history
of other countries meddling in the
elections of other countries
there's a long history of americans
trying to exert our preferences
at the high government level on the
elections of other countries and this is
sort of an ongoing thing and what
matters is
we protect our system from any meddling
the problem with making that case for
people like william barr
is that william barr and mitch mcconnell
and donald trump they've all had
opportunities to strengthen our election
system so that it
is less uh subject to the manipulations
of foreign countries they've not done it
and and of course the speculation is
they've not done it
because they think that on balance the
meddling including from russia is good
for donald trump that's the reality
instead bar just says oh
china's really the worst one and it
makes it sort of an adjudication of
china versus russia the implication of
course being
that china wants biden to win which is
really a question mark but it's
something that's been been repeated
whereas russia wants trump to win the
reason
that there's a sort of base rape fallacy
with these ideas that
if ex-country wants biden to win it's
because biden will be in their pocket
the reality is that most countries sorry
most countries have an interest in the
more
stable united states so
china may well want joe biden to be
president instead of trump
because trump is an unstable maniac iran
may well want biden instead of trump
because biden maybe would stick to his
word
instead of how donald trump just bailed
on the iran deal despite iran not having
done anything wrong so
just because a country prefers one
candidate over another
doesn't mean that they're they have that
preference
for nefarious reasons russia
specifically
we know because it's in black and white
and it's been in black and white for
decades
their goal to seize and grow
their power globally is
to make western democracies appear
unstable and that's why they would
support donald trump so there's a real
apples to spark plugs comparison going
on here
now wolf blitzer getting back to
how many indictments have there been for
voter fraud if voter fraud
really is the problem you claim it is
how many indictments have there been
uh william barr tells us several ten
years attorney general of the united
states how many indictments
have you brought against people
committing voter fraud
i couldn't tell you off the top of my
head but several
i know like a handful i i can't i don't
know
but several doesn't sound like too many
well i don't know i don't know how many
we have
i know there are a number of
investigations right now some very big
ones in states
the president also has said and i'm
quoting him directly
and wolf blitzer is right in a country
of 331 million
with billions of votes cast over the
last however many election cycles
uh several cases of voter fraud
really isn't a lot it's not hundreds
it's not
thousands it's not anything that comes
even close to impacting
the election results and then william
barr insists
we simply haven't tried mail-in voting
so
it's a question mark it's a black hole
anything could happen
we haven't seen widespread fraud but so
far we haven't tried it well
the point is that a lot of us there are
several states that only have
mail-in voting including a republican
this is playing with fire
this is playing with fire we're very
closely divided country here
and if people have to have confidence in
the results of the election and the
legitimacy of the government
and people trying to change the rules to
this to this methodology which as a
matter of logic
is very open to fraud and coercion
is reckless and dangerous and people are
playing with fire
well i will point out there are five
states that only have mainland voting
including utah and colorado washington
state oregon
uh hawaii and they they've reported over
the years they've had virtually no
problems but who's trying to change the
rules right now i would say the people
who want to go to mass mail and
ballots but you understand why there is
a coronavirus pandemic
right and there are a lot of people uh
potentially if they waited long lines
uh when they go to the polls uh and they
could get they could get sick
especially older people or people with
underlying conditions
as a result a lot of people want to
change the rules so they don't have to
go waiting
well they don't have to touch all this
the appropriate way to deal with that
is number one arrangements at the polls
that protect people which can be done
now of course we have tried it we have
systems in place we're just doing more
of it this year because of a pandemic
it's the same ballots it's the same
processes
it's the same postal service unless of
course donald trump manages to kneecap
it
kneecap it and william barr gives a hint
about what this this is really about
william barr says listen this is a
closely divided country
and what that means is if too many
people are able to vote safely
it could be really bad for donald trump
that's the code that william barr is
using when he says
listen we've got to be careful this is a
closely divided country that's right
that's right and that's why the idea
from trump is
suppress the vote that we know will be
disproportionately a vote for joe biden
people taking coronavirus more seriously
are more likely to vote by mail
if you suppress vote by mail you're more
likely to suppress
more biden votes than you are trump
votes
so um here is wolf explaining
to william barr that you can't vote
twice that it's illegal
to try to do it willfully it's illegal
despite donald trump's encouragements
which i'll get to momentarily take a
look at this
and then let them go vote and if the
system is as good as they say it is
then obviously they won't be able to
vote it sounds like he's cur
encouraging people to break the law and
try to vote twice
well i don't know exactly what he was
saying but it seems to me what he's
saying is he's trying to make the point
that uh the ability to monitor this
system is is not good and
and if it was so good if you tried to
vote a second time you would be caught
if you voted in person that would be
illegal if they did that if somebody
mailed in a ballot and then actually
showed up uh to vote in person
uh that would be illegal i don't know
what the law in the particular state
said you can't vote twice
well i don't know what the law in the
particular state says and when that vote
becomes financial any state that says
you can vote twice
well there's some you know maybe that
you can change your vote up to a
particular time i don't know what the
law is
i'm not going to offer he was saying
tesla you know because he doesn't know
what he's saying why are you asking me
what he's saying
he doesn't believe in the mail in voting
you're the attorney general of the
united states
right well the little experiment that
william barr is talking about there
would be a crime
we've never seen anything like this the
attorney general says
he doesn't know what the law is about
voting
around the country but he's sure based
on
logic as he said to wolf blitzer that
foreign countries are going to try to
print and send in millions of ballots
what's going on is unprecedented this is
a red alert
not a rehearsal and next i want to get
to donald trump actually suggesting
suggesting that voters commit what in
north carolina
is a felony if you are anything like me
you probably aren't thrilled with the
idea of going into
a doctor's office right now and
thankfully there's a practical
and affordable way to take control of
your health
and get personalized care from the
comfort of your home it's a service
called steady md they're one of our
sponsors
you take a quiz you get matched with a
licensed
primary care physician who understands
your health needs you have a one hour
video call with your new doctor
you establish a meaningful relationship
with them and after that
your doctor is available to you anytime
by text phone or video chat this is not
a random doctor on call
each doctor at steady md has a limited
number of patients so they actually have
time
to listen to you you get the personal
attention that you deserve
they can do almost everything an
in-person doctor can do
perform medical evaluations talk to you
about health concerns
send prescriptions to your home or local
pharmacy
and anything they can't do online
they'll quickly set you up with
an in-person provider to do things like
blood tests as an example
you don't need insurance it's only 99
bucks a month with
no other fees or copays there are so
many
practical advantages to using steadymd
for primary care
and it's also so much more affordable
go to steadymd.com pacman to take the
free quiz
see which doctor is right for you i took
their quiz they matched me with
a doctor who specializes in my
particular health needs and situation
the doctor they gave me
is a really perfect fit for me and my
medical needs there's no risk no
commitment to get started
just click the link right underneath
this video